Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Después del estallido de la
Revolución Francesa en 1789,
Europa quedó sumida en el caos.
Los monarcas de países vecinos temían
compartir el destino de Luis XVI,
y atacaron a la Nueva República,
mientras Francia se desangraba por el
extremismo y la desconfianza entre bandos.
En medio de todo este conflicto,
asume el poder una figura poderosa.
Pero ¿salvó a la revolución
o la destruyó?
"Orden, orden, ¿quién es la parte
demandada hoy? No veo a nadie".
"Su Señoría, es Napoleón Bonaparte,
el tirano que invadió casi toda Europa
para compensar su inseguridad personal
debido a su baja estatura".
"En realidad, Napoleón tenía
la altura promedio del momento.
La idea de su baja estatura viene solo
de la propaganda de guerra británica.
Y no era un tirano.
Evitaba que las
monarquías europeas aplastaran
a la joven República".
"¿Derrocando a su gobierno
y tomando el poder para sí?"
"Su Señoría, como joven
y exitoso oficial militar,
Napoleón apoyaba completamente
la Revolución Francesa,
y sus ideales de libertad,
igualdad y fraternidad.
Pero los revolucionarios no pudieron
asumir un verdadero liderazgo.
Robespierre y los jacobinos,
que llegaron primero al poder,
desataron un reino de terror
en la población
con su extremismo anticatólico
y las ejecuciones masivas de todo
el que discrepara con ellos.
El Directorio que los reemplazó era
una oligarquía inestable e incompetente.
Necesitaban un líder fuerte que pudiera
gobernar con prudencia y justicia".
"Es decir, ¿Francia pasó
por toda esa revolución
solo para terminar teniendo
otro gobernante todopoderoso?"
"No exactamente.
Los nuevos poderes de Napoleón
se derivaron de la constitución
aprobada por una votación popular
en el Consulado".
"¡Ja! La constitución fue casi dictada
a punta de pistola en un golpe militar,
y el público solo aceptó al tirano
porque estaba cansado de
la constante guerra civil".
"Sea como fuere,
Napoleón introdujo una nueva
constitución y un código legal
que mantienen intactos algunos de los
logros más importantes de la Revolución:
la libertad religiosa,
la abolición de los
privilegios hereditarios,
y la igualdad ante la ley
para todos los hombres".
"Todos los hombres, por cierto.
Privó a las mujeres de los derechos
que la Revolución les había dado
e incluso reinstauró la esclavitud
en las colonias francesas.
Haití todavía se está recuperando
de las consecuencias siglos más tarde.
¿Qué clase de igualdad es esa?"
"La única igualdad que podía
ser estable en esa época,
y estaba incluso muy por delante
de los vecinos de Francia".
"Hablando de vecinos, ¿qué pasó
con todas las invasiones?"
"Muy buena pregunta, Señoría".
"¿De qué invasiones estamos hablando?
Fueron los imperios vecinos
quienes habían invadido Francia
tratando de restaurar la monarquía
y evitar así la propagación
de la libertad por Europa,
dos veces en tiempos de Napoleón.
Después de defender a Francia como
soldado y general en esas guerras,
él sabía que la mejor defensa
es un buen ataque".
"¿Un ataque contra todo el continente?
En 1802 se aseguró la paz,
y otras potencias europeas reconocieron
el nuevo régimen francés.
Pero Bonaparte no podía descansar hasta
tener el control de todo el continente,
y él solo sabía luchar.
Trató de hacer cumplir un bloqueo
a Gran Bretaña a escala europea,
invadió a todo país que no cumplió,
y lanzó más guerras para
mantener sus ganancias.
¿Y cuál fue el resultado?
Millones de muertos
en todo el continente,
e hizo añicos el orden internacional".
"Se le olvidó la otra consecuencia:
la propagación de los ideales de
democracia y libertad en toda Europa.
El continente se reformó
gracias a Napoleón,
pasó de un mosaico caótico de
territorios feudales y religiosos
a estados-nación seculares,
eficientes, modernos,
donde las personas detentaron
más poder y derechos que nunca antes".
"¿Hay que agradecerle también
el ascenso del nacionalismo
y el aumento masivo
del tamaño del ejército?
Se puede ver lo bien que
resultó un siglo más tarde".
"¿Cómo sería la historia europea
de no haber sido por Napoleón?"
"Inimaginablemente mejor/peor".
El ímpetu imparable de Napoleón
moriría en las nieves del invierno ruso,
junto con la mayor parte de su ejército.
Pero incluso después de haber
sido depuesto y exiliado,
se negó a darse por vencido,
escapando de prisión y lanzando
un audaz intento de restaurar su imperio
antes de ser derrotado
por segunda y última vez.
Bonaparte fue un gobernante
lleno de contradicciones,
que defendió una revolución popular
imponiendo una dictadura absoluta,
y difundió los ideales de libertad
mediante guerras imperiales,
aunque nunca alcanzó su sueño
de conquistar Europa,
sin duda dejó su huella en Europa,
para bien o para mal.